her cousins he has pushed himself to a
higher level and i think it's going to
continue oh baby i can't believe i just
saw you pick kirk cousins
i mean the love hate continues
i love him he's your guy
follow him i love him not kirk cousins
is kind of a dork i love him
i'll get kirk cousins tattooed left arm
i love him not i don't like it at kirk
cousins
[Music]
oh here we go
[Music]
one of their four third round picks took
texas a m quarterback helen maughan
you interviewed him i interviewed him
i was a big fan before he became
potential future vikings quarterback and
who knows how it's going to play out
this is all a projection this is
developmental pick but
the vikings
keeping their cards close to the vest
understanding what they're facing and
from their perspective
see the difference between the aaron
rodgers situation the kirk cousins
situations is cousin's contract he's
under contract for two more years
shireen williams and i interviewed him
back before the super bowl and he made
it clear he's not interested in an
extension and there's no way as a
practical matter they can franchise tag
him in 2023 they needed a plan or he was
going to have all the leverage and they
were going to have to give him whatever
he wanted to keep him after these two
years so they decided you know what
guy we like
third round pick it's not going to make
a huge wave
we're going gonna go get him we're gonna
develop him that's our leverage that's
our protection that's our alternative
our plan b that could could become plan
a
after the 2022 season the vikings if
this guy develops they seize back the
power from kirk cousins again they can
say to kirk hey sorry we we're just
gonna we're gonna turn to this guy we're
not gonna pay you 45 million dollars a
year we're not going to pay you top of
the market you want to go get paid top
of the market go to the market
i think that's what
what drove this for the vikings and it
worked out perfectly the kellen mond
look at that ball look at that in stride
launched it that he ended up he ended up
being there in round three they were
thinking about justin fields at pick 14.
what's that tell you they know they
needed a plan for post 2022 and now they
have one yeah they got one and yeah i
think i mean they got a steal and a
quarterback like helen monde you know in
the third round he's got the talent and
everything the pedigree whatever it is
to be a starting quarterback in the nfl
you know that was one of the things i
loved about his game anyways mike i mean
he just he had been playing nfl football
there in the sec with texas a m as far
as throws in the pocket and doing all
that he's a great fit for how
your vikings play on the offensive side
of the ball because yeah he's a strong
arm guy but he's a good athlete he's a
better athlete than kirk cousins this is
a guy that's you know low four six high
four five type of speed and then throws
the ball on the run phenomenal so and
then you just saw that that would be
that would be something similar he would
do
if he was playing on the vikings offense
where they could do because of his arm
strength where they'd go hey let's do a
little play action to the right we'll
set the pocket up behind the left tackle
and we want you to set up and launch a a
corner post to justin jefferson for
60-something yards so yeah this is not
like a threat to kirk cousins this year
right now and that's the good thing
about it being a third round pick i
don't think anybody will expect it to be
but i think you're totally right this is
a guy that has starting quarterback
pedigree and to me after the big five i
know kyle trask was taken before him
this was to me the only guy that left in
the draft that had legit
big time starting nfl potential that i
really looked at him that that way so
it's a great fit and he's uh is a
talented football player we'll see how
it plays out
there is value in being that third round
quarterback because
the the questions aren't there the
attention isn't there you can develop
quietly while the other guy continues to
play and that seems to be the plan don't
take my word for it here is rick
spielman the vikings general manager on
what having monde on the roster means
for kirk cousins
with a pick like cohen is that a
situation where you feel like you need
to call kirk and kind of explain it to
him or is it just you know hey we picked
somebody and there's more competition
and and it doesn't really need to kirk's
are starting yeah the kirks are starting
quarterback it's not there's no
competition there
it's just taking another player it's
like regardless of position if we take a
player in the third round or first round
i'm not calling a player and say hey we
may take this guy here
our job is to try to get as many good
players in here and let them all come in
and compete
look i it gets back to aaron rodgers
again at what point do you give the guy
a heads up but
i
yeah
i think that cousins is aware or should
have been aware yeah that they'd be
looking for a quarterback to develop
because of the contractual situation
because he didn't want to extend it this
year and i don't know that they even
tried to get him to extend and reduce
the cap charge this year well why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you you've got
him under contract for two years
and you know the way it's structured if
he gets to the market if he gets the end
of the contract he's getting to the
market you can't tag him uh if he said
to them politely now i'm fine with the
next two years of my contract and they
got to take care of their business and
they did now spielman also said that
cousins is clearly the starter
there's no question about that right but
he also said monde was one of their top
players on the board and his quote was
that you see him right in that area as
where the top three quarterbacks went so
they believe in him
the way i do that you believe in him
right
and no one else did or he wouldn't have
been there in round three chris no no
you know it and it's one of those things
this is what we see here i mean second
round quarterbacks i don't even know if
that's gonna really happen anymore it's
like you get the ones that are in you
know top need in the first round the
second round everybody's so worried
about hey there's only so many good
players on the board and that seems to
be the new thing here and then kind of
the third round everybody starts to all
right let's address some of the
quarterbacks you know these second-tier
guys and when they seem to go but yeah
it's a smart pick by then i think for
the future you know for the player them
himself the way he fits there uh it all
makes sense he's played a lot of
football he's got good pedigree as far
as you know understanding how to read
defenses and read an offensive play
that's the one thing jimbo fisher really
did for him too so at the very least too
he's a really high quality backup for a
team too where he's he's one of these
rookies where you just go oh yeah he can
be our backup and we can trust he'll be
on his game week after week after week
but i i love the pick and kirk cousins
has let's just let me just say this
he's played really good football the
last three years really good football
there's no i mean it's it's special but
yes there's a little bit of a limitation
on
what he can do for a good team and
making it great as you've always
mentioned he's not going to be the kind
of guy that can just go
wait get on my shoulders it's a bad day
we got bad pass protection and people
aren't open and i'll dice them up he
needs a little bit
system help to kind of do that and get
it going so yes that's where he's not
special that way and what i guess i'm
basically saying is when you're that
type of player this day and age in the
nfl and if your team's not really good
around you and you're not making like
deep playoff runs then they're always
looking to replace you two to three
years down the road i mean that's really
that's really just life in the nfl right
now unless you're one of the really the
the five ten special quarterbacks in the
league
well and and the bottom line is that
the off schedule plays
the off schedule throws
those are things that kirk cousins can't
make he can't buy the time with his legs
to get away from the pressure the walls
close in and that's it i can't tell you
how many times i've seen him with that
kind of running in molasses
trying to get out of the pocket to
extend a play and he gets gobbled up
that's not him he gets out of the pocket
and then he just got to the point where
he just he just he that's it just hit
the deck like peyton manning no that's
not what he does and the the quarterback
position is moving toward finding the
guys
who can do the off-schedule things it's
one of the reasons why the 49ers yeah
talk about that at some point today fell
in love with trey lance right he can do
the off schedule stuff and kyle shanahan
seems to be warming up to a guy who
doesn't do exactly what the play calls
for because you have to account for the
possibility that the play is going to go
to crap and the quarterback's going to
have to pull a rabbit out of his hat or
some other orifice and he saw that with
patrick mahomes we've all seen it with
patrick holmes and i think every team
now wants a guy that can do that when
the play doesn't work
can you make something happen on your
own monde better suited to do that than
cousin
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports